uh anything
um new going on with the I know your
your guys's families was suing that was
at the city of La or the LAPD or uh
promoters Live Nation anything going on
with the Live Nation lawsuit it's been
since Corona so I don't know we just sit
and wait but sitting and waiting I'm
having a business so you know yeah
you're making you're making you're
making sure you're not sitting around
like waiting to see what happens yeah
now I can imagine man I've been to like
events recently and I feel like that
lawsuit has shaken up the music industry
because now when you go to these
festivals it is crazy how like
you're out of there like you perform and
you have to leave like I think I think
people I don't know
um
legendary performance for sure